- All right so we are,
we're gonna to start in a few minutes.
Probably a few seconds.
- [Phillipe] You're online on Twitter,
should see the Twitter.
- Should we start?
- [Phillipe] Let's put this online.
Okay then, go ahead, ready.
- Hello, well, thanks
everyone for joining.
The whole idea of this livestream
and we're thinking of doing
this as regularly as we can,
is obviously the world is going through
something of a crisis right now
around the COVID, coronavirus.
And a part of that, obviously people are,
first and foremost,
concerned about their and
the community's health
and the spread of the virus
and how to best stop that.
But then, there's obviously
side-on effects of that
and one of them is that we're starting
to see increasing school closures.
Obviously, other countries,
like South Korea, Japan,
and more recently Italy and France,
have closed down schools entirely.
And we're starting to
see that in the US now.
My children's school
was closed as of today.
And obviously, Khan Academy,
a non-profit mission of
free world-class education
for anyone, anywhere.
The way that we've
tried to help doing that
is by creating resources online
that could be used in
conjunction with classrooms
that could also be used
independently by students.
We think this is our duty
to really step up now
and make sure that as
many students as possible
feel supported as possible,
as many parents as
possible feel supported,
as many teachers as
possible feel supported.
So, what we're gonna do today,
and this is all a little
bit of improvisation,
is I'll tell you what I've been telling.
We've been getting a lot of inquiries
from various outlets and things.
I'll tell you what we've
been telling everyone.
What resources we're
gonna try to put together
and then, I'd just love to take questions
from anyone out there,
whether you're a parent, student, teacher,
or whether you're just someone
who's curious about things.
So, big picture, what we're saying,
so first of all Khan Academy,
many of y'all are familiar with it.
We do have a lot of the core resources
that students of all ages would need
to be able to keep learning.
If you start at the youngest age level,
we have Khan Academy Kids.
Khan Academy Kids is for as
young as ages two to three,
but it will adapt the students all the way
to through the first grade standards.
We've just added the
first grade standards,
and that's in reading, writing, math,
and social-emotional learning.
We can talk about the
ideal use case for it,
I think for that younger crowd,
maybe 20 minutes a day
or at least no more
than 20 minute sessions.
Ideally, sitting on the
lap or sitting next to
a parent or loved one who can
work through it with them.
But that could be an
interesting starting point
and we'll talk more about
some of the ways that you
could structure your day.
As you get into early elementary,
mid-elementary, late-elementary
and even middle school,
on the English and Language Arts side,
we actually just launched,
it's actually not even launched,
it's a beta of our
English and Language Arts.
It's not perfect, we have
to make some product changes
so that it can better work
for the English and
Language Arts modality.
But it has some really
great content on it already.
So, if you go to the Khan Academy,
the main dropdown menu on the top left.
You'll see, when the menu comes down,
you'll see it on the bottom right,
it'll say ELA Beta,
and then, you can pick the
appropriate grade level.
Once again, I'll talk more
about how to use that,
but that has reading comprehension,
which is, I think, one of
the most important things
for parents and students
and teachers to keep up with
while we're going through
this unfortunate situation.
On the math side,
this is probably what
we're most known for.
A lot of people associate
us with those videos,
but actually I think the
most valuable thing we offer
is the ability for students to practice
as much as they need,
in any concept, all standards aligned,
at their own time and pace.
That goes all the way from
the kindergarten standards.
And, so do have an overlap
between Khan Academy Kids and the website,
where I would say if a student
is just learning to
read, still quite young,
Khan Academy Kids is a better resource.
But if you're, for the
kindergarten, first-grade standards,
but if you have a second grader
who could use the remediation
or could use to go back,
you've heard teachers
say they like to start
all their students back at kindergarten.
That actually could be
useful to just make sure
they have no Swiss cheese gaps.
But for sure, once you get to
second, third, fourth grade,
all the way through middle
school, high school, and college,
we've got you covered on
the math side of things.
And then, as you go into a high school
science and social studies,
we have most of the core
subjects there as well.
And then, on top of that we have
the official SAT practice with this,
which is math, reading, and writing.
I think that's appropriate
for any high school student
and even some precocious
middle school students,
if they wanna just make sure they
get that practice in those three areas.
And for enrichment, I think
our computer programming
is really a lot of fun
and it could be a really good way
to spend some down time
if students are at home.
The thing that I'm emphasizing
and we're emphasizing
as a team to parents,
is try to keep things--
Don't try to do everything all at once.
It's not even healthy (laughs)
to be in front of a screen
for eight hours a day
while schools are closed.
Try to focus first on just
the core fundamentals,
and then, if that's working,
then, layer on from there.
In our minds, the core fundamentals are
the reading, the math, and the writing.
The reading, you could use
our English and Language Arts
for students to get
practice reading passages,
answering comprehension questions on it.
So, that's a good source
of reading practice.
And also just reading books,
it's really that simple.
We hope over the next week to send out
some reading lists and things
like that to make it easier
for parents and teachers
and students on their own,
to know what types of
resources they can look at.
On the math side,
depending on the age range,
and we're gonna send
out archetype schedules
over the next week.
But for younger students,
I think sessions of about 20 minutes
is about appropriate.
The important thing is
to just do the reading
and do the math every day.
That's what really makes a difference.
That will keep students from forgetting
over this time period.
And, I believe actually can
help them, push them forward.
And, if you can get that
reading and that math,
I would say, even two hours a day
is just the core base
for students of any age,
I think you're not going to be regressing
over this period
and might be progressing.
And then, from there
you can layer on more,
especially for older students.
And, I think once you get to middle school
and high school students,
we can offer almost a full, complete day.
And, we're also gonna send other resources
that are out there, podcasts,
other things you can read,
magazines that are good to read,
in this obviously very interesting time
that our globe (chuckles) is facing.
So, that's the initial thinking right now.
If you go to Khan Academy,
you'll see a little banner that says,
"Hey, if you're seeing school closures
because of the virus, click here."
And, you'll see an evolving page
that has our resources,
how do you get started, etc, etc.
Some of what I just talked about,
we haven't put up yet so
please come on a daily basis,
it's going to be changing regularly.
I'm hoping by Monday or Tuesday,
we're going to put those schedules up.
So, if you are a student
or if you have a child
or if you're a teacher of children
who are of certain age groups,
what could a schedule look like for them,
including things like breaks.
Making sure everyone
gets time to run around
and play and explore and pay attention
to the news and all of that.
But with that, I'd love to
take questions that folks have.
My colleague, Irene,
she's got a laptop here.
- Hi, everyone.
- We've got this light coming
through the blinds that's--
- This light.
It's been great to get
people's questions in.
So, let me sound share some with you.
From Kristin Allen, we have a question of,
"Is there a social-emotional learning
on Khan Academy for
first and second grade?"
- So, thanks for that question.
So on Khan Academy Kids,
we do have social-emotional learning.
Social-emotional learning
is a very broad space,
but for Khan Academy Kids,
that is definitely
integrated into that offering
and that's appropriate through students
up to six years old,
go through the six-year old standards.
We don't have a deep
social-emotional learning
offering on Khan Academy Proper.
I think that is a good call-out,
and as we ramp up materials,
I think it would be powerful for us
to think about how do we that, too
'cause a lot of what we've been building
over the many many years that are
I think going to be valuable
for people of this period.
We've been very focused
on your core academics.
but I think what we're trying to do,
this live stream was really the first.
Our first run at this,
is try to give people
a sense of community,
try to give people a
sense of connectedness,
as we are all socially
isolating, so to speak.
And, also give folks
materials and things to do.
So, you're gonna see all
of us at Khan Academy
broadening what we're talking about.
I think you're gonna,
as you see the schedules
and things that we put out next week,
we're gonna say,
"This is your time to play."
"This is your time to meditate maybe."
We're also gonna be exploring
with other partners,
ways that we can all
interact in deeper ways
so, that we don't all
feel completely isolated.
And, also there is a lot of learning
that's going on in the
broader world right now.
What's a virus?
How does it spread?
What's the proper response to it?
What's the economic
implications of all of this?
How are social interactions
going to change,
maybe forever, after this?
So, there's a lot of real-life learning
that I think kids could, (laughs)
and actually all of us,
could benefit of from in this period.
- Yeah, there is a lot.
But Kristin Allen, I just wanted to say
that her question was about
the first and second grades.
Be sure to check out Khan Kids.
You can download that app.
There are no ads in it,
no in-app purchases.
And, all the characters
really were designed
specifically to foster those tips
We've got more questions coming in.
- [Phillipe] One good thing to clarify,
on the Facebook page,
they see my name on there,
because it's originating,
it says Phillipe live. (laughs)
- Okay, Phillipe just told
us on the Facebook page,
you might be seeing, "Phillipe Live."
That's still us, it's fully--
- [Phillipe] It's originating from
the video manager here. (laughs)
- Okay, yes, Phillipe is our video manager
and he's right on the other side
of the screen. (Phillipe chuckles)
- We got a few more questions.
Wanna get some more?
- Yes.
- So from Sadia, how do you
encourage elementary kids?
- Yeah, so that's--
When we put out these,
we're gonna hopefully
by Monday or Tuesday,
have schedules that you can say,
"Okay, if I have an elementary school."
Let's say that I have a
seven-year old, eight-year old.
What could the day look
like for that student?
And, it's gonna have
something like wake up,
change out of PJs,
really have a regular schedule.
Find a place in the
house that feels like--
It's not like you're just slouched over
on a couch with the TV running
and you're trying to do a
little learning on the side.
It should actually feel like,
okay, this is kind of school.
We're actually going to
consult with more experts
and hopefully, as we do
more of these live streams,
which we're targeting
to do on a daily basis
through this crisis.
I'm hoping to bring some experts in
who can help us with that, too.
But some of our first stabs at it
would be create incentives, that schedule.
We'll try to set up like a checklist.
We might even try to
create some frameworks,
that hey, "If at student is able to do
X, Y, and Z in a given day,"
"Here's some treats or some
benefits they might get."
There might be a little bit
of quid pro quo with your child. (laughs)
If they're able to do this really focused,
good screen time,
maybe they could get a little bit
of less academic screen time.
There could be other benefits.
And, one of the things
that we're trying to do
with these live streams
is we wanna be a little bit
of a clearing house, too.
If you're a parent who has come up
with really good
frameworks, we would love--
Send it to us.
- And post.
- And post, and post.
- I already see from people, saying,
"I use Khan Academy all
the time in the summer."
Or, "I've been homeschooling
with Khan Academy."
So, if you've developed
some tips or techniques
about how you motivate your kids,
please post them and share.
We want our whole community to
to benefit from your tips.
- And, email skhan@khanacademy.org.
Email it to us, if we
see really cool stuff,
we'll be sure to give you credit.
We'll say, "Hey, this is
what Sadia came up with
(laughs)for her children."
This is an adaptation of it.
It seems to be working for her.
This could good for if you have
seven- or eight-year old
children or whatever age group.
So we're going to be working on that.
What are the motivation mechanisms?
Another thing that we are contemplating
and we're trying to figure out how we can
resource this and do these things.
Are there ways that we can we can help
in real time?
Communicate with your children
and provide them some frameworks
during the course of the day.
So, that's something that
we are very seriously
looking into our next week and beyond.
- We've got some more questions gaming in.
From Jennifer Goldstein.
How well do the online lessons align
with the Common Core?
- So, the lessons,
Khan Academy has been
building for the building
around a Common Core for,
since the Common Core existed.
So, the lessons that you'll
see in math from K through 12,
and the lessons you see
on Khan Academy Kids,
and the lessons you see in
English and Language Arts
from which are grades two
through eight on Khan Academy,
these are not only aligned
to the Common Core,
most of them have had external review
from some of the, even varied
people who helped develop
the company for us.
So, they are very, very
much standards aligned.
If you're in a state that
isn't the Common Core State,
I would say that there's more alignment
than you would think.
Or any other country that does not
follow the US standards.
First of all, we have actually
40 translated versions
of Khan Academy.
If you go to the website,
you'll see the link
at the top of banner.
Spanish is the most built out one.
But our belief, especially,
in a time like this,
if students are able to engage
in high quality materials
that are aligned with a rigorous standard
and Common Core is a rigorous standard.
I'm very confident that they will progress
in almost any standard that's relevant.
I think the important thing now
with what's going on with school closures
is to just keep students learning
on high quality materials.
Make sure their reading
skills don't atrophy.
Make sure their math skills don't atrophy.
Make sure their writing
skills don't atrophy.
And, there might be a
glass half full opportunity
for them to may be even get more practice
in this time, a little bit more focus.
- Okay, and I don't know
if Jennifer was a teacher,
but just in case for all
the teachers out there,
you can actually put the
Common Core Standards
into our search box,
and then, it'll just pull up the videos
and the exercises associated with them.
From Jessica Knap, do you
think this would be good for--
This time would be good for SAT curriculum
for 10th and 11th graders?
- Yes, I think this is actually a--
For those of you who don't know,
back in 2015, we created this partnership
with the College Board.
Khan Academy's official
practice for the SAT.
And, it's in math, reading and writing.
Today, a majority of all
kids are taking the SATs.
Use it when you take the PSAT.
If students get permission,
their scores can be linked with
their Khan Academy account.
And, then, it acts as a
diagnostic for Khan Academy.
And, one thing that we've
always been focused on
both us and the College Board is,
we don't view this as just as SAT Prep.
We view this as preparing
for you for college
as measured by the SAT.
And actually, so, the SAT
practice on Khan Academy metric
is an excellent way to,
as I said, you can't let--
To keep those reading comprehension,
math and the writing skills sharp.
Because actually,
writing and you can write
and it's auto graded by another partner.
And, so even if you're not
taking the SATs in the near term,
I think if you're a ninth grader or above,
it can be a great thing to engage with,
because you're gonna to get practice
in all of the major domains.
And, obviously, that will likely
reflect and improve your SAT score.
One of the issues in high school normally,
is that you're so overloaded.
You have six classes you're taking
and then, you're doing many hours
of homework at night
and then, you have to prepare
for things like SATs or other tests.
And, you have to do that on the margin.
You could view this as an
opportunity to say hey,
"Look, if you could put in--
As a high school student,
if you're able to put in
even an hour a day on SAT practice,
maybe 30 minutes on the
English-Language Arts' side,
30 minutes of math side,
even that is going to make a massive gain.
And, as a high school student,
or parents of high school students,
I'm assuming there'll be even
more self regulation, (laughs)
and then, you can spend some more time.
So, I wouldn't do five hours a day.
I think that would not be healthy.
But if you can do sessions of,
"Okay, I'm going to go
deep for 40 minutes."
"Then, I'm gonna take a 20-minute break."
"I'm gonna go deep again for 30 minutes."
"Take a 20-minute break."
There is this whole thing
called the Pomodoro technique,
which is a technique for
avoiding procrastination,
which we all struggle with many times.
And it is--
Set a timer that you're
going to be focused,
can be 20 minutes, 30 minutes, 40 minutes.
I definitely won't recommend
more than 40 minutes.
And then at the end of that,
give yourself another.
Set the timer again.
Give yourself a 15-minute break,
or a 20-minute break, whatever you want.
Hopefully something healthy.
Go take a walk, go for a run,
do something, get outside
and then, dive back in.
And if you're going to
do the SAT practice,
we've actually been doing some analytics.
It's not fully public yet.
But the important thing is not to just--
It's to do as much things
that are pushing your
learning as possible.
So, take those full length
practice tests that you can.
The recommendations, we've
seen some associations
that the students are able to
follow the recommendations,
which are always trying to push you
that they're potentially seeing more gains
than with the kids are just
randomly jumping around on it.
So, simple answer is yes.
I think the SAT practice
is a very good way
to stay engaged in all the core subjects
in the mastering of them.
- Okay, and the questions keep pulling in.
So, now, we have actually
from another Khan,
a T. Khan. (Saul chuckles)
Are you planning to
coordinate with teachers?
We are doing a lot of that in this area.
- Simple answer is yes.
We had a webinar yesterday.
This is just, what you're seeing right now
is just the very tip of the iceberg.
We hope to go for this to build momentum.
So, we hope to, throughout this whole,
for lack of a better word, crisis,
we hope to connect with
teachers, support teachers.
We're trying to talk to
other technology platforms
and figure out what type of resources
we might be able to--
We also want to be a
clearinghouse to find out that,
"Hey, someone has figured
out, a teacher has figured out
a good way to virtualize their classroom."
We want to share it with folks.
Obviously, not just using
resources like Khan Academy.
Whatever resources are out there.
But yes, we want to support
teachers through this,
parents through this
and teach and students through this.
- Can I just give some
practical ways to get started?
So for teachers, specifically,
we have a Teach With Khan Group.
So, go to Teach With Khan.
You'll be able to connect
with all sorts of teachers
and they can give you
tips how to get started.
If you go to our homepage
and click that little blue ribbon,
it'll take you to a blog article
and the link linking to teacher resources.
So, we'll just have all sorts of videos,
webinars and resources to help you
get the best outcome for your students.
Let's see, we have from Owen Yinka.
I'm sorry if I am--
And, is there a solution for remote places
where internet access
is a major challenge?
- So, Owen Yinka,
we don't have a really
elegant solution there.
Our apps, Khan Academy
Kids does work offline.
And, our Khan Academy
main app does allow you
to store some of your content
but we don't have a really good
truly offline solution for the main stream
Khan Academy yet.
That is one of the gaps,
obviously around the world.
We know that's an issue
and in this situation.
I know a lot of public schools
who are struggling with this issue of,
if we close the school,
which is probably prudent at this point
for the spread of the virus,
how do you ensure that all kids
have access?
Now, we are fully accessible--
- There's Kolibri, remember?
I think one of our--
If you go to Kolibri--
- Yes, it used to be known as KA LITE,
Kolibri which is an offline,
so, you can look into that.
- And, that's spelled K-O-L-I-B-R-I.
Look into that.
- Yes, maybe even if
you just search KA LITE,
it might show up as well.
And, that one is something,
I think that's really valuable,
if you are able--
Well, you should look into it.
I actually haven't looked recently
at what their (mumbles) is.
But that's I think that's more of--
Yeah, people should look into that.
I think that's a little harder
for an individual to consume on their own.
But they should try.
- Our team just wants to remind us
that you can go download the videos
on the Khan Academy app
if you want to watch offline.
Let's see, we also have,
from Melinda Wedding,
are there any plans that help AP kids
who might be missing the
last few weeks of prep
before the main tests?
- Yeah, that's an excellent question.
Actually, I mean, we
want what we're all gonna
try to make what we can of this situation.
You could actually view this
as a glass-half full
because traditionally, AP tests,
which I know, there are
things that students
want time to prepare for,
they're rigorous exams.
It's usually hard as you go onto May.
Students have all their other classes,
all their other homework
and then, between the gaps,
they have to prepare for AP.
I don't know where the
College Board is on--
I know some of the SAT administrations
have been moved around.
I don't know what's going to happen in May
with the AP administration.
I hope they move forward
or maybe they can delay it a little bit.
We'll see.
We don't know what the world
is going to be like in
April, much less May.
But I think it is prudent,
for kids to assume that
testing is going to happen
as scheduled.
And, I think that's where we can
be really really helpful for folks.
We have, on Khan Academy,
AP Calculus, AP Statistics,
AP Biology, AP Physics.
We are actually in development
of our new version of our AP Chemistry
but we have Chemistry,
the high school and
college level on the site.
We have AP Microeconomics, Macroeconomics,
American History.
AP Government and Civics,
AP Computer Science Principles.
And so, I would recommend if
the students are able to put,
well, now they'll have more time,
if they are able to put 30 minutes a day,
40 minutes a day, an hour a day
into each of the subjects
that they're plan on taking
the AP test in come May,
I think they're going
to do very very well.
As I mentioned earlier,
what we have isn't just videos,
it's exercises and these
exercises have been vetted
by third parties.
These are the same third parties
who've helped develop things like AP
or in so many cases, helped grade the APs.
So, really is highly rigorous materials.
So, what I would recommend
is go on Khan Academy,
every course we have--
Most of our courses, we
have something called,
Mastery Enabled.
What that means is not
only do we have exercises,
but it's enabled in a way
that it has game mechanics
that try to measure
students' knowledge state
on their current skills.
If a student is already feeling
like they've already
covered most of the year
in their AP class,
they can go immediately to what's called,
A Course Challenge
and take that course challenge
which should take them about
40 minutes, 45 minutes.
And, then, they'll see which units
they're strong or weak in.
And then, especially, the
units they are weak in,
they could then, go to each of these units
and there's things called Unit Tests.
And then, based on that,
that'll take about 30 minutes,
and then, they could get a skill breakdown
of which skills they missed.
And then, they can go skill by skill.
And the way that you get level up a skill,
you can either go to a particular skill
and get a certain percentage
of them right every time
and we have a very deep item bank.
So, you really shouldn't
see a lot of repeats.
And, then, if you see that skill again,
and mix a little practice
on the unit test,
or a course challenge.
Or what we have now, is
called Master Challenges
which is based on just repetition review.
Then, it'll get leveled up.
So, I'm actually very confident
that if students who are taking AP,
put in 30 minutes to an
hour per day, per AP,
they're actually going
to be quite prepared.
And, I would to add,
as you get to the last
few weeks of the AP,
to augment that with--
Khan Academy will, I think
prepare you very well
for the multiple choice portion of the AP.
For the free response of the AP,
and most of the APs we
have worked examples of
free response,
and so, there I would recommend
that the student start the video,
pause it right before
I'm about to or one of our team members
is about work through the example.
And then, work through it themselves
before the video does it.
That's the best way to
consume type of content.
But yeah, I think AP is
very powerful use case
for the students that are studying for it.
- Great.
And, we're getting close to 9.30
but do you have time for another question?
- I have time.
I have a harsh stop at 10 so we can...
- Okay, let's keep going right now.
From Gita Gandhi,
can parents assign things to kids,
I know I can do so as a teacher,
but wasn't sure about as a parent?
- So, there's two things.
Actually, so, first of all,
what we used to call coaches
or teacher tools are available to anyone.
It's not like we check
that you are a certified
teacher when you--
It's predominantly used by teachers.
So, we have both parent
tools and teacher tools.
The teacher tools are more powerful.
They're built to be able to support
a larger number of students
and things like that.
And so, from the teacher tools,
for sure, you can make assignments,
you can assign specific skills
you can assign full units,
you can assign things like unit tests,
you can assign things like Course Mastery.
So, I want students to achieve
mastery in this subject
via a certain date.
On the parent side, you
can definitely monitor.
Can you do assignments
from the parent dashboard?
I would say if you want to do assignments,
it's safest thing is to
use the teacher tools.
- Yeah.
They're free.
Free teacher.
- And that's actually where we have
more sophisticated tools anyway
and you'll just be a teacher
with however many kids you have
as your students. (chuckles)
- Let's see, from Sadia,
this is a great question
for us to start thinking about.
How can the teacher reach out to students
during the school closures?
- Yeah, we're brain storming that.
- We're in the early
stages of thinking on this.
I know that at my school district,
our teachers and superintendent
were just talking about that
and we're going to start
off with the easiest
and most familiar
techniques like group email.
Parents and the teacher
communicating through emails.
Some other school systems are using
Class Dojo where other tips
or system for that type of communication.
And maybe this question also means,
how do you continue to foster
that sense of community
when you're teaching
online as opposed to being
in a physical classroom?
- I think what we're going to try to do,
and this is all improvisation.
I think we're all improvising
over the next few weeks.
So, putting aside all the
things we're hoping to do,
I think there might be
a convergence here is,
there is a world where if you do have,
it could be Google Meet,
it could be Zoom,
it could be some of these other tools
that allows some form
of video conferencing
and messaging at the same time.
It would be, I think
pretty cool for teachers
to be able to communicate students that,
"Look, I'm going to
available at these times."
Obviously, it could be
coordinated with the schools.
Well, I do know some schools,
my children's school,
their schedule is going to be 90% same.
And, they're going to
be using theses types
of video conferencing tools
to essentially run their program.
Now, that's, I would say the best case
and we know that's a lot
of schools haven't had time
to plan and do that type of thing.
And so, I would say, I think
it would be interesting
if, at the same time, we put out
what archetype schedules
that could look like
for students of different age groups.
It could be really interesting
if teachers are able to also message
with their students and say,
"Hey, if you follow this schedule--
And obviously, the app schedule
or whatever you think is appropriate
for your students.
"If you follow this schedule,
I, too, the teacher, I will be available
at these times at this link."
At the Google Hangout
or on the Skype link,
or whatever else,
and then, you could actually have
a virtual station rotation model
because some of your students,
Okay, it's 9 a.m., the schedule says,
"Work on your Khan
Academy math for an hour,"
but the students also know
that you, as a teacher are available.
So, if they have any questions,
they can go to you,
they can just literally change
the window and say, "Hey."
It's like office hours.
So, some of the students
might be working with you,
and then, you can do deeper problems
or more challenging problems
or you might even ping
some students on tools
like Slack, or some messenger
or something like that
and say, "Hey, I see
you're having trouble,"
because you can look at
the Khan Academy dashboard.
"I see that you're
struggling on this concept,
why don't you come into my office hours?"
Essentially, open up a different tab,
and, "I want to work
with you a little bit."
I think that could be really really cool
if students are able to
get that type of support
while they're working on
tools like Khan Academy.
And obviously, as a teacher
able to do the lesson plans
that you were already planning to do,
that's even cooler.
And, even in the classroom,
you think the best use case is,
teachers are able to do
their traditional lesson plan
in highly collaborative ways
and that that's 20, 30% of the time
that students are able
to personalize learning
on the platforms like Khan Academy,
where the teachers are
still being able to see
what work the kids on working on,
what they're struggling with
and where interventions are appropriate.
But in this type of a context,
it might make sense to
have more of the student
self-work but have a lot
of support from teachers.
- Okay.
Let's see from Wasi, we have a question.
I want to home school my children,
do you have any recommendations?
I do want to, off the bat mention,
that we actually have a parent webinar,
mark their calendars,
it is next Wednesday
and knew we will be also recording it
and make that recording live.
- Yeah, and--
- And, you can register.
Just go to our homepage.
You can register for the parent webinar.
- Yeah, so the parent webinar.
And, the simple answer is
everything we've been talking
about on this live stream,
I think is relevant if
you're looking to home school
your child, depending on the age group.
As I said, most of the resources--
Sorry, we have this life from my blinds.
Most of the resources you need,
Khan Academy has been
working on it for many years.
Math for sure, we can help students learn
at their own time and pace
starting as early as pre-K,
with Khan Academy Kids
which goes to first grade.
And, you can pick up from there,
all the way through high school
and early college
mathematics on Khan Academy.
Students can learn at
their own time and pace.
We're going to try to put out--
We already have a lot
of materials out there.
Things like the webinar are
going to be very valuable,
for getting a little
bit more tactical help
but we're going to put a lot of resources
out there for different age groups.
What could the schedule look like,
where one of the Khan Academy
resources can be relevant
in each of those periods in the schedule
and what other resources
should folks tap into?
Books that might be available
online or not online,
podcasts that can be good
sources of discussion.
So, we're going to try to support you
as much as possible.
The reality is a large chunk of the world
is being forced to home
school on some level.
So, I think, we're going to do our best.
So, yeah, please keep telling
us what questions you have.
As I said before, my email
is skhan@academy.org.
We want your questions, your ideas,
things that would work for you.
We would love to then,
share with everyone else.
- Yeah, we really appreciate
what's been rolling in.
I know that Jeremy who
held our teacher webinar
last night has already had
a list of 1300 questions,
between the survey we sent out and the--
So, what we are doing us,
we're going through all of their questions
so that we can create
and get the experts in
and create the webinars and the tips
that will be really helpful.
So, we're going to keep on doing this.
- Yeah.
Are there questions?
- Let's see, we've gotten
through, let's see.
From Shaun Rhodes, does
your program use games
to teach concepts?
And, he talks about having
a child who's autistic
at home and wasn't able to make it through
his multiplication tables until they found
an online game to master it,
and then, he was able to master
those skills (mumbles).
- Yeah, so, to some degree
is the simple answer.
I think Khan Academy Kids is the richest
and that's for younger kids.
But that's a very rich
game like environment.
As you get into the
main core Khan Academy,
we have some game mechanics,
we have things like energy points,
master points, avatars.
The whole mastery mechanics,
you try to level them up,
you get them fed when you reach
certain levels on the site.
So, we have those types of game mechanics
but it isn't like a--
There is a spectrum between
game and academic learning
and we always say,
we gotta to make sure that
we cover the standards
and how can we layer as
much game and motivation
mechanics on top of that.
But we're constantly
trying to improve that.
Every year, we try to make improvements
to make it even more
engaging and motivating
for students.
You brought up a really interesting point
around multiplication.
Or actually, two things.
We haven't done official studies
of Khan Academy with students
with various learning needs
whether they're autistic spectrum
or whether learning needs,
ADHD or dyslexia,
but we have had a lot
of anecdotal feedback
that being able to learn
at your time and pace,
being able to get as much
practice and feedback
as you need,
we do have some game mechanics
being able to pause, repeat, watch videos
at different speeds
is valuable for folks.
On the point you brought up
about the multiplication tables,
I think that's a super valuable one.
Khan Academy gives practice
on things like that
but nothing can beat--
This is just a great bonding experience
for some of that.
If your child is second grade,
third grade, fourth grade,
make sure they have that fluency
in their core math facts.
We can give a lot of practice
on the different standards on Khan Academy
but there is nothing like
sitting with your mom or dad
or sibling or teacher
and making sure you have
your single digit addition,
math facts really fluent and making--
And, once you get to
second or third grade,
making sure you have your
multiplication math facts
really really fluent.
I can't tell you how many students
we've seen who are in fourth grade
or fifth grade or sixth grade
or even sometimes high school,
who you can still tell,
too much of their cognitive load
is trying to figure out
what eight times nine is.
So, they can't focus on the other math.
And, so you'll be doing
your kids a big favor,
by just making sure they're super fluent
at that stuff if they're
not there already.
So, should we--
- I think what we can do is wrap up
because we're going to be doing this again
as soon as what? Monday? Tuesday?
- Yeah, I think that's the hope.
It's been great.
A lot of great folks have chimed in.
I know this is a super tough time
for a lot of folks.
A lot of folks are trying to figure out--
I mean, yesterday I was working from home
and my kids were right next to me.
- You are on it.
I know my schools are closing on Monday.
I do wanna just do a quick shout out
to Teresa Bryant.
She just said, "Thank you
Saul this live stream."
"Because there are so
many parents out there
feeling panicky."
I think what's your message
if a teacher or somebody
is feeling panicked?
- Yeah, well, Teresa appreciate that.
I think
one of the main purposes of starting
this live stream today
is that we're all in this together.
We're parents, everyone's,
a lot of people.
But we're all trying to figure out this.
We are in a new--
Society has never gone through this,
at least in modern times.
And, I think for all of us,
honestly, for me, just to
even connect with y'all
right now, it's comforting
to me as well (laughs)
'cause I've been socially isolated
and so, I think the
best thing we can do is,
thank God that we have
these types of resources
so that we can connect
virtually right now.
But that's what I think it is.
I think this is going to be the time
that we're going to see
the best of humanity
really stepping forward.
It's our duty to help all of y'all,
parents, teachers, students
navigate this person.
We're going to be back on Monday.
I hope to be able to do this everyday
and don't be surprised if this grows
into more types of supports.
So that as many people as possible
are not feeling panicky.
I highly recommend meditation.
We've actually recorded
some guided mediations recently.
Something I've been doing
for the last year and a half.
I was getting quite
claustrophobic on planes
and someone recommended meditation.
That really helped me
reduce my claustrophobia
but it has had positive effects,
well beyond just my plane claustrophobia.
So, I highly recommend that.
Especially, with people feeling anxious
and they're just feeling
overwhelmed by things.
Just 10 minutes a day, five minutes a day.
Just sit silently, try
to absorb your thoughts,
realize that everything's going
to get better in the end.
We just have to put one
foot in front of the other
and just do the next right thing.
I was telling that to myself
and my children yesterday
because everyone is like,
"What's going on?"
Just like, look,
let's just do the next right thing,
for the next hour,
the next day, the next week.
It's all going to work out.
I think there's going to be
some glass half full moments.
And, I think we're going to see
the best of everyone, step forward
and we'll do what we can on our side.
So, thanks to everyone.
- Thank you.
- For being part of this.
- Onto the next right thing
for the next hour then.
- (laughs) Yes, that's right.
- Okay.